welcome this is going to be a very
special video very special man you know
and I've got my friend here to join me
as
well so this video what we're going to
be doing inshah this man here is a
silver back he's a natural bodybuilder
Muslim bodybuilder one of the few
Pioneers in the industry I would say you
know and uh he's been very active in in
in so in so doing what I was going to
ask you is basically what I wanted to
present to the people the follow it yeah
yeah people are live a very hectic life
working life yeah for sure and we can't
go to the gym and do weights five times
a week or six times a week like a
bodybuild right um so really what is
feasible what is practical what's
pragmatic what's the right thing to do
is maybe three times a week if we if
that so what I wanted you to do okay is
I wanted you to present a series of
videos yeah of a 3 Day split today being
the first day the push dat can you
explain how what is a 3-day split um and
what is a push day let's do it
that's hope you guys are doing well so I
appreciate you getting me on the channel
and uh so Muhammad hijab obviously as
you just mentioned uh you want to
basically present to the people a nice
routine for the busy man who's whatever
very hectic lifestyle to train three
times a week and the split usually that
works really well is a push pull sorry
it's a leg day first then you do a push
day and then you do a pull day that's
the ideal way so in today's video we're
going through a push day a push day
consists of your chest shoulders and
triceps so these are all the muscles
that usually work best or the muscles
contracted the most when you're pressing
so or pushing as you call it now yeah
the real question is when you have um a
gargantuan you know beast from the
Middle East like me will you be able to
actually give me something that will
satisfy me that will push me through the
paces and which will actually making me
feel like have done a workout let's find
out guys remember most crucial part
warming up the Rota class before you
start lifting heavy so very simple get
the cables don't do it with dumbbells
it's wrong with dumbbells when you get
to here there's no more tension on that
Rota C muscles so do it with cables that
lateral Force that's pulling that way is
what you want for the Rota CU muscles to
probably warm up so do about 20 reps two
sets on each side and you're good to go
all right guys one more warmup set you
can record it are one more warm up set
I'm just showing the form here quickly
so there a few pointers that you got to
take care of as I showed in his shot but
basically eyes align with the bar Arch
on the lower back shoulders pinch into
the bar shoulders pinch into the bar and
it's just a warmup set so let's get it
all right we had some technical diff
difficulties we have to change camera
all right bro first working set 100
kilos let's get it so he's using chalk
for the first time let's see if he
thinks it has any difference okay
muhamad one one thing you finish your
set though but you're too far up the
bench yeah you want to be eyes and line
with the bar go on Too Tall let me tell
you do you know when I come B closer
he's just he's just talking and benching
kilos when I come closer to the bar yeah
sometimes when I'm here yeah unless I'm
here and I'm I'm moving sometimes the
bar gets in the way of these things
that's so that's why you should be this
way and then when you lift off you come
forward with the bar trust me that's the
whole point of when I say eyes in line
with the bar yeah that's the whole
Point all
right this is our work bro so nothing
crazy 12 let's go for
[Music]
like three
strong four keep going easy up
one
ni look good bro you know how is no
really really
good up
[Music]
all right people L heavy
set all right two clean
[Music]
I another no would trust me atast one
more you did
that
you yeah so don't wait yeah so B how you
feeling bro feeling good m a strong set
there on 120 from the Middle East come
on so uh
Mah he did the 120 very comfortably so
added on another 10 again as I said
overloading the muscle Progressive
overload going a bit heavier I think you
got five reps in you bro yeah maybe less
cuz this is a bit L yeah I'll say three
to five reps I'm going to go for about
three um shoulder injury but no exes
yeah but inah let's get it
Man 2 1 let's go press easy press nice
deeper
get it get it get it get it come on come
on come on got let's go press press keep
going you see what you did there yeah
usually unless you really want to like
kind of push out for I don't always
recomend like see when you fail I leave
it that you injury as well it yeah good
reaching the the my my liit all right
guys inah
three three reps let's
see come
on come on
[Music]
come this
got I just touched it so I don't count
that third rep guys so that's how it is
in my
book I mean
you I'm feeling good man time for the
back off set it feels like seriously it
feels like this is training in it BR
definitely training come on bro let's
get it so we're going to go now down to
100 kilos and we're just going to rep it
out to
failure predictions what do you think
you're going to get how many reps I'm
not good with this you're not sure at
[Laughter]
least all right so what is I was just
telling I I was telling silver back
right here yeah I look up my heart rate
quite often in the gym whether I'm doing
cardio shadow box whatever I'm doing so
right now my heart rate is quite high
it's about 132 130 y okay and that's a
bit too high to continue doing a um a
new set so what I will do there's a
happy medium a gold lock Zone it's not
too low so my resting heart rate is like
say 77 or 80 yeah which is quite high
for the rest but I won't wait for it to
go to that but I'm not going to do it
like this either in weight so what I'll
do ideally is I'll go down to about 100
when it's about 100 I think that's the
The goldilock Zone you're still in the
working Zone yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right right guys comment how many reps
he's going to get in in if you can get
bro so I'm going to say to you yeah try
eight minimum eight minimum eight but go
to failure so I'm only going to touch
the bar when I see you're about to
basically fail
okay it's recording bro yeah take your
time get M get
mentally you
it 3 2 1 let's
go yes 1 2 3 4
5 6 come on 7 keep going eight let's
work 9 let's go finish it finish it
another one press come on 11 bre come
almost almost got 11 well we said more
than eight so well done bro all right
guys I'm going to try for like 10 to 12
let's see what we can
[Music]
do all right
let's do this
[Music]
leave it leave
it if I done one more would have F and
you all right guys so second exercise we
just push a moving on to incline
dumbbell press again four working sets
now we're already warm so don't really
need to warm up rep R all right so show
us the form here yeah okay so this one
you don't have to worry too much about
the path of the weight so it's just
punching it straight up in the air but
be sure to just punch it straight and
then slowly bring it together but don't
bring it together right from the
beginning cuz the kind have a tendency
to clap on I'm sure you've seen the gym
fails all
[Music]
right full range of
motion 11 is 11 yeah that's 10 I think
oh okay I was kind ofing it different
bro
[Music]
see now that noise that he just made is
what makes everyone angry in the
gym let's get it bro Muhammad's got long
arms so for you it's more difficult more
range of motion the weight has to travel
further wait about to touch the
ceiling don't uh flare your elbows out
too wide yeah so you want your elbows to
be about
45° so you flared out a bit too much try
and bring that elbows
in come
on keep going bro keep
working keep
working come
on strong come on strong strong strong
what come on come on leave at that good
man
masah good job I wasn't counting so good
job I don't know what you
done huh all right Muhammad just told me
a about so the mo is gone here I better
get more than what did I get in the last
set 12 as well I think so yeah I better
get more than 12 if you get this then
I'll be
impressed I better get more than 12
after why I just
heard maybe we'll drop it later on let's
go let's go 1 2 3 4 5 good 6 7 8 good
good n this is 10 right y good man two
more I have to get 12 come on come on
come on come on come on don't sto don't
sto
go push it just push it this is this is
determination here that's that that that
set there spoke a lot about your
character your fortitude kind of a man
the silver
back yeah so Muhammad just asked why
don't we do dumbbell flies here I'm not
going to say it's an incorrect exercise
however when you're doing DB flights
when you're lay so imagine I'm laying
down I'm Contracting the weight bringing
it in it's all working it's all load on
the muscle but when we get to here the
contraction dies cuz now it's just
gravity pushing down towards you so the
best thing to do is go on the cable that
has a lateral Force pulling your arms
apart so even when you're here there's
contraction pulling your pulling your
chest Mar this way and you're fighting
it like this you
understand tell us what you're doing
first so moving on to Cable flies yeah
as I mentioned earlier best way to
contract a muscle where you putting this
thing you see this thing where you
putting it this various versions you can
do high to low okay of course put it
high more be lower chest put it in line
of your shoulders yeah you fly in front
of you kind of overall P the and then
you can do low to high okay your upper
chest all right so what we doing now we
wanted to go overall so going to Lun
forward and we're going to front of us
and what kind of weight are we using
here not too heavy but you want to rep
it out from 16 to 20 reps oh okay okay
okay
right good form so okay this is
important now the form here yeah how you
doing this you don't bring your
shoulders forward you bring your
shoulders forward you're going to work
your anterior belt too much shoulders
back chest open up your PS squeeze open
up all the way squeeze don't if you see
my chest working but it's working
just to show you guys if you do like
this it's lower chest okay and if you do
low to high it's upper chest and we're
just do to overall pet development
[Music]
here all right that's good lighting bro
here looking like a unit yeah there good
lighting here so hands in front of you
start position hands in front of you
there you go shoulders back good posture
let's go squeeze the chest together so
mind to muscle don't think think about
any other muscle in your body except
your pecks of course you're going to
feel it in the front of your shoulders
little bit on your biceps just more of
like a a pull but ultimately just focus
on your
chest come on
good nice and wide nice and
wide squeeze the chest muscles keep
working keep working bro come
on give me four more okay let's go
y
yep good man
nice it's good aldah look at a beast bro
yeah but it's uh Muhammad moving on next
exercise bro tell him what we're doing
wait wait wait hold your horses I
thought I just
jump show so we super setting yeah uh
yeah so this is me telling them what you
told
me this way this machine from the chest
Y and uh then we're going to do a super
set with the these kind of things here
what Lal leral Rises Lal Rises yeah this
machine here and jump straight onto it
straight away benefits are time
efficient get crazy pumped and um again
we're going for a high rep range and
what's what we looking at here so we got
2 20s on each side there let's go for
about 10 reps minimum 10 10 10 and above
and then match it 10 and above all right
let's go bro all right M moving come on
two you got it three four strong 5 6
7even come on 8 N9 all the way up all
the way up all the way up it's fatiguing
yeah right straight away bro so with
this one dumbbells by your side and just
raise him there we go keep
going very nice very
nice good man keep going keep going
let's go match it yeah 10 reps at least
strong remember the breathing yeah come
on good man M smooth
bro smooth all right keep it rolling
let's
go same 10 10
pluss first time
[Applause]
beautiful man my magic number what was
that 16 oh I was about to say man what
are you doing all right let's go
[Music]
fantastic fantastic brilliant you can
never have big enough L head you
always all right I'm going try try eight
bre let's do it man finish strong
fatig in mind
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful come on boy come on
one
more come on come on come on push it oh
no have a breath let's do it how one
more one more come
on usually I wouldn't do this okay you
really no but let's do cuz you said
let's do it okay let's do it I bet it
don't fil but when you start something
you have to finish it that's true come
on that's true let's go let's go
push up just one that's the
one you do enough one for okay there you
go there you have it there you have it
see I think the people are more
interested in this
[Laughter]
now this is good man this is this is the
secret the secret is hard work come on
Brea in breae
in good yeah all right ready all right
guys so that's most of the shoulders now
we did the that supered the anterior and
the lateral head last part of the
shoulders the rear delt so the shoulders
made up of fre muscles anterior latal
rear you want to hit the rear now I
telling mhammad about balance you want
to have balance you can't have one area
so what we're going to do face P
exercise P KN straight up what we want
to do you want to pull the bres towards
your forehead go between your eyes and
you also pull your arm keeping your
elbows
up Focus mind to muscle over the back of
shoulders nothing else squeeze stretch
squeeze there is another variation where
you can go here that works rot as well
do either one it doesn't matter I'll
just
one squeeze
second again 16 to 20 reps going heavier
and heav on
every here they can
see does this work a bit at your back as
well bro yeah of course it works across
your upper back but if you have the
great
way turn you're up okay let's go bro I'm
going to go lighter only I haven't done
go one lighter go 17 and a half yeah
face this way the lighting is going to
be good next shot do it this way come
hold it this
way so let's show them the grip you want
to hold it like this towards me face me
come towards me this way this
way yeah all right elbows up step step
back more step back step back step back
you got long arms bro stra straighten up
your arms now pull there you go so you
want to focus on the muscle right here
do you feel it good man that's it m to
muscle bro keep your elbows up keep your
elbows up pull your hands apart as well
yeah hold it for a split let's go speed
up the tempo a little bit let's go there
you go but hold it elbows up don't let
the elbows drop there you
go there you go raise your elbows bro
raise them raise there we go that's what
I want to see squeeze it keep it up at
all times Don't Let It Drop keep it up
keep it up as you're going back keep up
as you're going back as well good
man that's it good all right so I
mentioning earlier keep your elbows up
so if you watch me see elbow stay nice
and
High second and slowly bring it back
explosive bring it
[Music]
back since this is an isolation exercise
so first of all Let Go final exercise
yeah so that's chest done shoulders done
final push exercises of course triceps I
don't like to use the Straight bar cuz I
feel like it's a bit bad on your wrist
it's not really ideal for your wrist so
with this slightly e z bar your wrist is
at a slight angle feel a lot more
natural and comfortable so again with
triceps overload the muscle go heavier
on every set maintain like a 16 to 20
rep range most important thing when
doing this don't move your El so a lot
of people when they do this right they
know elbows move and they do this I see
what that's do creating momentum okay
that's momentum and you're going to do a
lot more taking the tension away from
your you're almost working your abs a
little bit as well right you can say
you what you can do elbow stay by your
side here beautiful okay do not move the
elbow if you had a training partner
would it be good for them to stabilize
you from the back I said could they
stabilize would that would that be
benefit yeah and four that's what you
want to do 16 20 reps and do about 3 to
four working
sets
go again most important thing mind to
muscle guys don't think about any of a
musle and your body just literally
living your
Tri it's a good therapy session
huh get it your set all right let's go
it's a good lighting as well
your say that huh literally
yeah living the muscle all right let's
go bro so step forward a little bit
forward forward sorry forward forward
yeah there you go okay so start position
there now do not move your elbows you
see your hands yeah your fingers are
over it I want you to get your hand over
the bar get move your hand over the
barall so move yeah get over it there
you go keep the barall in the palm of
your hand M there we go so you're kind
of working the overall tricep
development you have the short head and
you have the long head we're pretty much
hitting both there's different ways of
hitting the short head and the Long Head
we can get to that in another video but
for now this is more than sufficient you
say like the
main uh I would say the main for me
would be dips or close grip bench
anything compound compound exactly be
this is more for like accessory work
finishing off a
session nice
bro 16 to 20
just give me two
more last
one good man relax so how do you think
that went alhamdulillah solid session my
bro really good you tell me how was it
it was intense I have to be completely
honest as especially as it progressed
you know I thought I was done after the
bench thought I was going to go home up
to be honest guys yeah when it came to
the bench press you smashed it like the
120 you were moving it easier to me as
you said what was your biggest concern
or your biggest weakness as if you want
to call it stamina if it wasn't
endurance bro you would have beasted
that session so much better well you
know I'm coming back after a long injury
keep keep it rolling keep it rolling
this way yeah well you know I'm coming
back after the the Palm embolism the
injury that I had you know was you know
a disease but alhamdulillah with people
like you I can get back quickly aldah
man stay consistent with it and
inshallah many more so what's next to
come we're going to do leg day next well
that's what that's what going to be a
real struggle for taller guy M 6'6 so
taller you are it is harder you have to
move the weight more to mechanics but
yeah leg day then a pool day as well so
with the guidance of the big man you're
a big man bro I was talking about me I
was going to
say to much too much I'll see you guys
later